il faut savoir se retirer faire une
pause au bon moment pour revenir plus
fort alors je le dis officiellement
c'est la fin des vidéos activités
manuelles pendant un moment tout comme
ça allez après tout c'est cuisant échec
et cette petite pause qui a trop duré
évidemment qu'on n'arrête pas les
activités manuelles parce qu'on adore sa
tendresse et des vidéos que j'adore
faire même si elles m'angoisse comme
j'avais déjà dit mais surtout ils
transmettent un truc très positif et je
reçois pas mal de story ou de petit
tweet ou de mails même de gens parmi
vous qui se sont mis à faire des trucs
manuel suite à ces vidéos donc je suis
très content et on est influencé ou pas
aujourd'hui on revient à quelque chose
de plus sage de plus calme quelque chose
dont il existe des traces qui date de
plus de 40 mille ans la peinture y
croyez moi nos enseignes à 40 me dont il
faisait des trucs géniaux en peinture ou
qui a intérêt à ce que je m'en sorte
parce que si quarante mille ans après où
je suis moins bon que ça m'énerve et je
vous le dis ça à m'énerver alors écoutez
je me suis renseigné un peu sur la
peinture bon évidemment on s'emparer de
tous les artistes picasso tout j'ai
sorti la rave de l'enfant c'est le nom
de peindre que te donne un enfant car il
manque de culture cet enfant c'est moi
c'est bon j'ai découvert ça je pourrais
que la peinture c'était toujours des
trucs très long très chaud à faire et c
est pas du tout bien game un peu comme
pour le dessin de fast peinture pas
comme on appelle ça m'est vraiment des
gens qui hantent six coups de pinceau
donc trente secondes de leur temps font
un tableau trop beau qui donne une forme
super chouette regardez vous allez voir
de quoi je parle c'est vraiment vraiment
incroyable c'est parti juste deux
couleurs sur le pinceau 5 petit coup de
pinceau et bam on a une merveilleuse
fleurs sais où je suis sensible à la
peinture ça y est j'ai hâte d'être
sensible la lecture maintenant
regardez ses jeux ses insolences cerceau
l'an ces insolents elle fait un super
dauphin cool moi je lâche et dans les
boutiques pour touristes à 15 mal ça lui
a pris 10 secondes fait chier quoi
hu à regarder juste avec les nuances de
bleu la extraordinaire extraordinaire
cette sensation de profondeur que ça
nous donne la voyez vous c'est le même
pinceau depuis le début c'est trop beau
mais c'est juste trop beau cherche
ok vous êtes en brocante avec votre
copine bafia instant ya des petites
peintures comme ça vous est celle-là
vous l'achetez tout de suite ça me fout
la haine
bon bref ce qui est intéressant c'est
doigts qu'avec des trucs très simple
avec un pinceau et de couleurs tu peux
faire un truc qui est vraiment joli ça
je trouve ça vraiment impressionné ça me
touche
voilà je fais ça vous touchera aussi
évidemment on va pas suivre des tutos
comme ça serait beaucoup trop ça
pourrait suivre les mêmes tuto qu'on
faisait
j'ai honte qu'on faisait au collège je
vais vous présenter quelqu'un qui
s'appelle peinture pour tous n'est ce
pas un nom de chaîne qui s'adresse
parfaitement à des gens comme nous
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo dans laquelle je vais vous montrer
comment peindre un arbre merci frérot
cut
regardez le résultat tout de suite c'est
parti au plat quatre minutes allaient
bref on arrête de crier dette immature
on va se concentrer
c'est le retour des vidéos manuel on n'a
pas droit de se rater il faut un minimum
de réussite d'ailleurs enfin le retour
aux sources parce que la première vidéo
qu'on avait faits manuel c'était on
faisait du dessin et leur fais de la
peinture c'est très proche cette petite
pause nous a fait mûrement réfléchir il
est temps de nous ressaisir
c'est parti j'ai demandé à lorraine de
m'acheter une blouse parce que j'en
avais marre [ __ ] tout mes fringues
dans les vidéos activités manuelles mais
c'est pas une blouse ça c'est un
déguisement de bouffon que gens voudront
pas de ma peinture avant même que je les
fais avec cet accoutrement
c'est chiant alors messieurs dames
laissez moi vous présenter le matériel
tout d'abord un petit pot de pinceau
évidemment un petit pot fabriqués par
mes soins j'ai fabriqué un truc une fois
dans ma vie et je suis le mec
immédiatement j'adore et bien évidemment
de la gouache en mars et la laque soir
dont je suis le plus fier make up la
petite palette ah bah oui je suis refait
de refaire sa vie de là c'est parti
alors avec une brosse plate
la terre d'ombré brûlé mélangé à un peu
de noirs trop d'infos terre d'ombré
brûlé c'est quoi ça du maringouin est ce
que j'appelle le jaune lumière de soleil
ombragé maintenant je dis chaude frères
jeu alors pinceau plat c'est celui là la
toile est un peu grande déjà on va
prendre une plus petite
excellent jeu commence à peindre le
tronc de mon homme et deux plus grosses
branches allez on se colle à quoi sert
le trou dans la planche
c'est pour passer pour la tenir annoncé
pour faire ça à un voiture dans la boue
pas mélangée à du noir pourquoi du noir
un arbre ses marrons gens pourquoi je
mets un jour marron et du noir parle
mieux ok allez à temps mais non mais
avant il ya il a fait un truc bleus
derrière lui il est où elle est où la
vidéo pour faire une toile bleue et
maintenant j'ai émissaires dans le
marron alain au pinceau on va utiliser
cet accessoire pour faire la poêle en
bleu ce parti comment le premier geste
peut être si nul avec un gros pincement
faut y aller cash
[Musique]
c'est très long c'est très long juste de
faire une toile bleue
[Musique]
ouais je sais là ça sert plus à rien
mais je fais ce genre je suis
perfectionniste tu connais les mecs je
les fais c'est pour ça que j'adore les
tec manuel ambiante un vieux des grains
des bleus moisi tous pourris sur mon
tableau qui va être moisi je me sens
trop bien j'ai un sentiment de
satisfaction fou c'est bizarre ok on
commence là on va le faire au même
endroit que je vais complètement
kopierre aux mecs je suis en train d'y
qu'est le parquet allez on continue
[Musique]
je fais les contours déjà est ce que
c'est une bonne idée au sein du chu
alors les branches par contre c'est
ricky quoi c'est juste un coup en fait
genre là celle-là il l'a fait tac de la
note qui part comme ça
ok mon gars bon et là il a de la gueule
ne répondez pas pour les branches plus
fine
j'utilise un petit pinceau magot
actuellement mais je suis debout
rejointe en moi je les fais j'ai fait en
tout cas les la suite c'est quoi
l'organisation et la forme de vos
branches doivent être organique
il est important de savoir qu'un tronc
ou une branche sont toujours de plus en
plus fins mehdi le au début j'y tiens
fait toute mémoire se rattraper allez on
y va
pas mal
[Musique]
la finesse de ses traits
il dit plus rien quand je vois mon arbre
dans le retour alors que je participe
aux la vache on peut maintenant
commencer à porter de la texture et de
la lumière à notre arbre
et au fait comment mais c'est fou
explique choisissez l'orientation de la
lumière sur votre tableau pour moi elle
vient d'en haut à gauche aille avec une
couleur moyenne ici de la sienne naturel
j'applique la peinture entre temps avec
une brosse plate en laissant visible ici
et là la couche inférieure
ça a l'air super dur mais j'ai rajouté
des couleurs sur la palette alors je
suis peu de temps eurazeo a mais ça
c'est bien çà çà çà ferait un truc bien
ça j'ai pas de ranger une espèce de doré
la malle van gogh et c'est ça aussi il
disait passe - l'espèce de doré la
[Musique]
vendée jusqu'à rigoureux viens de vomir
sur cet arbre
je travaille maintenant les détails de
les corses avec ma teinte la plus claire
un mélange devienne naturel de creux
jaune et de blanc adore faire un mélange
ça l'intéresse du ciel du jaune et du
blanc j'ai tout ça ça j'adore ça
satisfaisant ça
[Musique]
ça donne pas du tout ce qu'il fallait
c'est marrant ça c'est l'histoire de ma
vie
[Musique]
arrête toi arrête toi ça te plaît arrête
toi arrête toi tu en continu je te vois
continuer avec toi voilà maintenant il
faut juste retravailler les traces
dhombres les raisons de son fait
quelques petits réaux de lumière et
voici mon arbre terminée mais il parle
pas des sublimes feuilles qui vient de
faire au pied de l'arbre moi il est à
poil il a froid comment il fait c'est
trop beau avec un mélange de terre de
langres brûlé et deux arrêts tags à
terre dont brûler j'ai compris la terre
dont brûler si leur annonce est bon ouah
ah mais ça c'est faux d un pinceau à
poil méga souple mais j'en ai pas voilà
sa maman je crois faut appuyer venez
avec le pinceau
[Musique]
pas du tout je t'en supplie dis moi que
c'est fini je pense vous montrer
différents types d'armes de troncs et de
feuillages non c'est bon c'est bon teint
guette c'est cool ni calcul elle est
bien en fait là il a l'air triste
d'arbres on est d'accord pourquoi parce
que là on est en automne mais non
veulent printemps non veut plus feuilles
giuly punk bien fait un peu partout on
va suivre le tuto du coût de cette même
personne pour les feuilles et là notre
tableau va renaître
mais avec sandra le faire
mais ça fait plus mal que beaucoup
d'autres activités manuelles
[Musique]
diamond est stable ou bon est-ce qu'on
est bon c'est la fin de cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à me donner votre feedback
dans les commentaires va de la grosse
merde elle mais en fait je suis à moitié
satisfait mais j'arrive quand même être
satisfait de ça en fait ce qui est chose
c'est la technique lui l'agrément
admettre que des petits points de
peinture tac tac tac tac tac et moi
j'arrivais pas ça faisait des gros tard
je pense juste c'est un truc
d'expérience mais du coup je suis en
galère j'ai mal aux bras sa mâture et
j'ai mal nerveusement la gema j'ai envie
de faire voilà
bon j'ai dû vider lagarde sd là puisque
ça faisait une heure quand on est mais
en vrai que le recul c'est vraiment de
la merde ce que j'ai fait c'est vraiment
la grosse merde mais on va s'adapter sur
le deuxième tableau messieurs dames
[Musique]
alors la deuxième toile les amis ça va
être un peu plus un droit parce que la
deuxième fois elle va être très petit il
s'agit de la chaîne de cindy baril et
tous m'ont dit bonjour à cindy bonjour
s'est dit en gros s'il dit reprend les
vidéos d'un anglophone qui s'appelle
khayyam sauf qu'elle commente en france
et donc elle dit voilà il faut compter
couleur sa part souhaité cédera bref
cindy elle nous régale c'est une
interprète exceptionnel donc regarder
bien là la toile vous allez voir les
petites mais regardez moi bien le
résultat douze minutes plus tard la
tension
coc alors je fais pas les arbres jamais
je fais les argelés côté je m'en bats
les couilles moyenne utilise un gros
pinceau plat qu'ils chargent en blanc de
titane et comme vous pouvez le voir il
applique de manière horizontale pour
éviter les coups de pinceau ensuite il
revient avec un bleu primaire il
commence par l'appliquer en haut du
tableau et il va descendre dans
l'objectif de créer un dégradé
je suis mort c'est bon je suis foutu il
va commencer par créer un petit soleil
au milieu mais c'est ça qui manque pour
souvent tableau d'exception c'est un
petit soleil au milieu
voilà il est tout de suite bien mieux
[Musique]
mais que c'est cool pour le moment bon
c'est rien moins dégradée que lui mais
ça va franchement c'est pas dégueu allez
les nuages alors moi un mois riot
l'étape à la paire des nuages on va les
faire avec ce petit tout petit la
sucette en mousse on l'appelle c'est
très simple tu mets du blanc et ensuite
juste eu ta pote et voilà j'aimais nuage
marche pas
le mélange utilisé pour créer lot est
composé de bleu primaire avec une pointe
de blanc de titane
moi je vais faire une eau turquoise
comme dans les îles paradisiaques est ce
que je sais pas ce que je viens de rater
mon mélange de blanc et bleu et qu'il
est trop clair et est oui
[Musique]
il n'y a aucune [ __ ] nuances de bleu
dans ma mère ce n'est pas de l'eau c'est
une tache bleue on va créer du relief
targuer de ryan j'ai capté ont fondu
bleu plus foncé va faire des petites
touches par ci par là et c'est mieux la
bienvenue ans il commence par appliquer
une assez grande quantité dont brûlé une
fois que son ombre brûlé depuis le début
depuis le début c'était marqué là vous
voyez ont brûlé ok et là il va partir
sur du blanc je le sais pourquoi parce
que j'avais la suite en off mais je
voulais pas monter il va revenir avec du
blanc de titane et l'appliquer sur la
partie supérieure de celle ci
ça ne donne pas la même couleur que lui
alors j'ai mis les mêmes couleurs alors
là par contre là je commence j'ai mis
les deux mêmes couleurs que lui et
j'obtiens un truc qui n'est pas dû à
mais c'est une page de gravier bas on a
droit de l'adapter à son style à les
tableaux quoi vous pouvez voir qu'il est
en train de créer des dizaines de réaux
landes du beagle tu ne fais pas ce qu'il
est en train de faire je vois bien
cécile c'est hyper dur ça ce qui vient
de faire trois c'est un peu plus dur si
j'y arrive c'est bien ça donnera un
petit effet cool
non mais non mais rien ne marche là mais
là le moindre truc que j'entreprends
seuil à aucun résultat
ça fait mal coiffé ou je vous le dis
nous explique également qu au milieu de
cette ligne légumes est plus épaisse et
qu'en plus on va vers les extrémités
plus et sous les arbres
brian utilise un pinceau plat qu'ils
aient une taille plus petite et ils
appliquent bongrain il vous explique en
fait ça c'est juste la sous couche il va
voir si on les remercie d'exploitation
e
[Musique]
j'en ai chié mais bon ça tout le monde
le savait avant de vous montrer les
résultats de ce dernier tableau
j'aimerais tout d'abord adressé mon
respect le plus sincère envers tous les
gens qui payent rire cette vidéo il faut
être super passion super rigoureux bref
bravo à vous essayez de faire la
peinture c'est hyper ludique et amusant
c'est vraiment marrant si vous avez du
temps à perdre et que vous voulez un peu
développer votre créativité
c'est un bon moyen ou alors jouer à
minecraft comme moi bref on débriefe
dans un instant je voulais sans plus
tarder découvrir la peinture nacrée t on
à bronzette à madagascar et de l'autre
on a tempête en bretagne vient devant
leur mue blanc il est dans les cailloux
sais pas pourquoi le bleu on dirait du
ciel on dirait pas de l'eau les nuages
c'est bien très bon beaucoup de choses à
dire c'est hyper dur c'est bon c'est
hyper dur bien plus que ça n'en al'air
commencé à essayer de faire des petits
dégradée du contrat secret du relief et
ou dans le tableau c'est chaud et je
crois si ce qu'on appelle le rythme dans
un tableau comme pour la musique et un
truc s'appelle le rythme et moi le
rythme de mes tableaux il est éclaté ok
je vous jure quand je vois les tableaux
dans le retour c'est un on dirait une
blague
est ce que cette vidéo est une blague
bah oui évidemment mais déjà merci à ces
gens de faire des tutos peinture c'est
très cool s'avança accessible et c'est
super technique je vous avoue que la
seule fois de ma vie où j'ai fait de la
peinture c'était en arts plastiques au
collège et j'ai été moins bon que ça
quand même
il faut dire la vérité il ya quand même
un truc que je retiens c'est que j'ai
progressé en l'espace de deux heures
déjà les feuillages l'avant ça reste
dégueulasse évidemment mais c'est quand
même mieux que ceux qui à la 20 donc en
fait mine de rien tu progresses très
très vite
en fait c'est très technique en réalité
je ne considère pas du tout étonnamment
que c'est une défaite cette vidéo je
sais que c'est moche mais je sais c'est
moche et pour gaz et voilà les deux
tableaux c'est pas la mort non plus quoi
ça on dirait une plante à truffaut ça on
dirait un cataclysme mais en vrai même
l'arbre qui lie les cheveux bon tout ça
pour dire que on est revenu dans ce game
des activités manuelles
on est revenu on y un personne ne fait
des feuillages comme ça c'est vraiment
divin ex qui ont surtout bientôt à
d'autres vidéos est compris dans une
prochaine activité manuelle je sais déjà
ce fait je rigole d'avancé je vais me
régaler bref merci d'avoir regardé
d'avoir été pas
et n'oubliez pas de m'évaluer s'il vous
plaît évalué moi je veux finir sur tevez
hors du coup je dis n'importe quoi sam à
la vie ou à l'est mais à toi tu pars
avec moi c'est chat
[Musique]